what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today and or episode
999 John how are you I feel rebellious
how are you
I feel like conforming to imperialism
good ladies and gentlemen leave a like
that would be very much appreciated also
as always full length Reaction watch
along is re-sync up with your own copy
of Andor available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page your support
is just so expected I expect you to do
it so do it uh no it means a lot thank
you and uh yeah let's get to it
Park attended a separatist meeting two
years ago in John Barrow where he met a
woman who suggested that if he was
serious about politics he might like to
act as liaison for ferricks when he
returned home he was sent the fractal
radio unit you used yesterday afternoon
this unknown woman who recruited him to
the cause seemed less interested in
generating political activity on ferrics
than she was in using your planet's
unique commercial position to acquire
stolen Imperial equipment
were you aware that the buyer
your contact metpark only once before
being turned over to you oh
don't Express at all Bix o Simon Park
says you've had at least six meetings
he's aware of
don't look down and stop emoting he and
Andor
blowing up buildings and killing
security guards you're injured trying to
warn them
your co-worker is killed trying to win
your freedom oh
and really knows all you show respect
for Tim
when was the last time you spoke with
Cassie and Andor
I love how she gets comfortable framing
but because he's like uncomfortable
close-ups oh yeah good call first thing
you can do right now
poor me
come up with an entertaining lie big 41
shift tomorrow you are the next man out
you are the shortest of the shore
swap your idea me no it's a tiger are
you kidding
two wise move
[Music]
ment for them today always the next day
right
you know the drill don't get smart with
me shut up and door
extremely hostile to the concept of an
imperial refueling Center that was being
planned I say was because they created
such a stir that the local commanders
were granted permission to use any means
necessary and um
well they massacred them all there were
three communications officers monitoring
the documentation and they were found
hours later huddled together in various
states of emotional distress in a cruel
space beneath the ship's Bridge
we've taken the recordings and
modified them slightly layering
adjusting and we found a section of what
we believe are primarily children this
is so sadistic is he referring to those
flashbacks let me know when you're
willing to cooperate oh and if you're
having difficulty speaking just shake
your head from side to side
you'll want to be sure of that Bix
that you're cooperating fully
it's repeat listenings that cause the
most damage
we ready
uh I can handle it
elicit of children dying all the time
whoa
whoa
I love these cheeky Cuts back and forth
foreign
buddy what you got there
my prison Shank
[Music]
s
Everyone hold positions
raced
your man on the floor
hold your positions two men back
two weapons
no boots
no boots
silence
is touching the rail believe me now
the elevator's not wired nothing that
moves can fry you uh
we had time while they're coming down
now they'll just go back up no
stop
we shut it down halfway
take one guard one weapon
this is so clever
damn she looks so messed up when
when you smoke
go to hell
let me let me I can do it I know
it's ready up everybody
ready now who loves not making it out of
here just talked about this
he told you two minutes ago
do you think I don't want to win am I
working or not one rack up hours to lose
what are you waiting for your noble man
who laugh you're good at work ethic kill
him
oh man I guess you spoke keep her here
keep her alive is it hostage
there's a witness on Simon Park I don't
care I'd like to hang him make sure they
know who's in charge As You Wish yeah
they're not clear on that the public
order re-sentencing directive is the
next step on an all too predictable
March toward complete unchallenged
Authority
whoo
our second vow is to protect the power
and Independence of this remarkable
chamber this is so noticeable when they
turn off their light yeah they called
from the residence your cousin she's
arrived at the embassy
they said you'd want to know
cousin yeah Khan Mothman
[Laughter]
Ron mothma Don mothma something's wrong
whatever it is taking the time about it
what's going on I think it's level two
foreign
didn't load in they are counting so they
cut a power
some bad I mean you don't look confident
Andy Circus it takes a week for one word
to get all the way up here and you're
panicking about something that's
happening on the other side of the
building
how many hands does it take for one word
to get through up here it's a long way
Kino yes but you're good Kino you're
gonna give yourself a heart attack
damn Keener is just so desperate to keep
things in order so he can get the hell
out of here
it's amazing
her cousin's Vel father may have an
opinion let me see if he lets you wear
it he lets me do anything I want
dang real cousin or cousin
I don't know I call my fiance my cousin
so you know call my lover is my cousin
that's the only way I can get excited
the Empire doesn't rest one
the Rebellion comes first
pick what's left
tell me you're going home for a visit
they've been after me to find you of
course
just came through to see you first and
get cleaned up a bit they are cousins
seriously
please tell me you're being careful
things are happening
there's risk I'm starting to think where
I am he's got a spinning out of it you
took a vow
it fits
it's nice to see her positively
responsive to someone you gotta keep
your cousin around more often maybe your
husband wouldn't lighten up too how many
guards on each level you want out of
here alive turn that part of your mind
off
how many shifts you have left
217.
tell me what you know before you go
you've been warned
I think they care what we say
you're on your own with this you think
they're listening they're so fat and
stupid their ears are clogged
good luck to you you think they care
what we say nobody's listening how many
guards on each level
I don't even get a blanket no I guess
not just sleep on your arm and or return
to ferrics three nights after aldani
with money in his pocket you're trying
to connect aldani that's a bit of a
stretch
he was clean-shaven oh my God the facial
hair is becoming an important detail we
rendered a beard back onto his face
that's worth running down an aldani
connection would certainly amplify
interest
let's follow that up damn better now
leaving her in place and standing back
she's too old and frail for anything
serious and if nothing else she's our
bait she's the reason and or came back
absolutely communicate if they are we'll
know we're on her full time
I'm so proud of you and it comes so long
so far this is the prouder I become the
less I like you but keep going
well what happened we weren't told
anything you're kidding they don't know
about it if they were fried out
they're all gone oh my God what 100 men
I can't be right whoa I heard nothing
what did he say
they don't care it looks like someone's
gonna start helping out Ander what did
he say what happened on two yeah we
don't know we set them all free
whoa no
be careful we know the better this
maybe it's true
maybe it's not we have heard nothing
just another day
another shift oh my God
these lizarded [ __ ]
until we know what's going on
oh man any circus was a great addition
to this yeah says the complete opposite
thing with his face
aren't you a job
it's a uniform
I prepared two meals a day I moved
mountains to scrape you off the floor
and put you back on your feet what is
the return on my investment we were
talking about you
oh my gosh this is so relatable
all that time away on molana what if
I've let your neglect right be insane
imagine that
look back just months ago when you can
easily ignore me
Jennifer called I've been promoted
I knew they'd recognize your problems
yup I knew I was right to invest in you
as an asset
right
come on boys let's go
there I'm there I got it
you're doing good man
come on boys we can do this come on dude
you're so close
you remember Tay coma I do Mother's old
boyfriend we're in grade school together
at least you've not gone political
though all the interesting people are
getting very tedious these days no one
ever calls me tedious
foreign
we've chosen a side
we're fighting against the dark
we're making something of Our Lives
or you could just enjoy the money
hey you did your part go home damn this
does make it a hell of a lot more
personal
[Music]
the loneliest woman in the Galaxy are
you stalking me
I know you work here and I come
sometimes to see if I'll see you dang
just being in your presence
realized that life was worth living I
realized that if nothing else there was
Justice and Beauty in the galaxy and if
I just kept going
perhaps my deranged belief that there
was something better fitted for me in
the future this was like watching two
Psychopaths
him I know it you're out of your mind I
have already given you a second chance
you come near me again you pursue any of
this and I swear I'll have you in a cage
on the Outer Rim uh he got to you though
how can you know with his charm this
piercing stare cereal breath there's a
400 000 credit withdrawal that's proving
a bit of a problem it appears on The
Ledger then it vanishes how much trouble
am I in there's some trouble at all
unless they scan the accounts but that's
coming
and yeah you're a lot of trouble
a Chandra and Banker
with treasury relationships you have
someone in mind it's not a long list and
yet you're afraid to say who it is Davos
calden
he's a thug the wealthiest Thug Oh
he wants to meet here
Davos golden here you must be joking I
pushed back but
he insisted I could keep looking
time is not infinite
the Rebellion is not worth it
Jesus money headaches time we don't
create getting spooked can't hang on to
him we can't let him go destroy the ship
make it look like an accident there's
too much at stake if I have a creek I'd
be suspicious we want Krieger moving
forward what if we foul the ship an
accident something mechanical have the
pilot found dead in the cockpit what
would happen
if we did it quickly staged it properly
let it drift into traffic make it so top
priority quickly and carefully we leave
no Trace excellent work so hard
no who takes the shift by six racks and
three
table one in the Box
come on let's get this done
oh
what's going on buddy
inmates
tables in position
he gonna get fried
[Music]
jeez
this poor guy get going now
you want to go a few ships left are you
going home
man it's just like a heartbreaking
prison movies
in you for a while I'm going anywhere
his name's oolav I've seen him before
hold up
pay attention to everything Cassian he's
got 40 shifts left
so we just want something to get him
through the next few days that's another
option
what
you can't save him
nothing to save
is that a massive stroke oh no
what are you doing
I can't help him I can't help anyone
I need a bag and a trolley it's coming
space Kevorkian
he's lucky
he'll pass peacefully which is more I
can say for the rest of us another week
like this
and you'll be begging for what he's
getting
what do you mean
you heard me no elaborate you dick
you feel nothing
no
he's passed
oh no
keep my men in line what happened down
onto
I need a bag and a trolley I said it's
coming
he's trying to get him out of here
I made a mistake
a man who was just released on four
ended up back on two the next day well
got out on the floor and then they
killed them all
if it was released
you and me
you break back in at least your friend
is free you too on program now
up and on your heads boom
let's go come on let's go looks like you
gotta start working together to get out
of here you know what to do
each level
11 more than 12.
oh come on
to
the most badass a number as the last
line has ever been
alrighty so that was uh that was a good
episode that was really thrilling one
picking up just just so soon after the
the last episode which was already
really great but much more deliberate
this had a uh a very like
Tick-Tock pulse about it all like you
could feel there was some
some death or something impending just
looming around the corner on on each
Stone and I love how
how just
everything's ramping up without it
relying on action scenes it's just
ramping up with takeover like now that
the Empire is taking it serious this
rebellious threat and and just how much
they're going in there or torturing
bicks and even with this prison system
that got set up like something goes
wrong and oops annihilate everyone on
level two
I think it's scary like you do forget
about where this well this is all
ultimately going and I appreciate that
about the show appreciate about it a lot
because
they're they're still they're so good at
like introducing even newer characters
and it helps to have someone like Andy
Circus as uh this Kino character where
you know it's Andy Circus so you know
he's going to bring something special to
it even if it's something small he'll
bring something special and I love how
substantial his character is becoming
and the way they have done the Arc in
such clever witty sort of dialogue with
a first Cassian trying to uh ring out
some information from him and he's
refusing to volunteer because it's all
about just sticking it through until the
very end and he can finally get out of
there clear
but then the revelations at the very end
of this episode just force them like
okay no I got no choice but to breakout
and survive
I'm worried that Kino will die I am
concerned that he'll die because you
know he has at the end of the day really
giving it his all and you can see in
this episode that he actually has care
he's not just some like ruthless hard
ass he really does eventually like have
moments that just kind of peek through
the clouds a little bit to show it no
this guy does really actually care he's
just a very militant about it all and
now
now it's it's time to be as desperate as
everyone else and to have someone I mean
you're trapped in prison with the right
guy you're you're casting and or who's
gonna climb his way up the top of any
group he's in
despite not having aspirations
apparently but but clearly to the
contrary yeah so it's really cool to to
see what they're doing there I'm really
liking a lot everything with this the
whole prison setting and everything that
feels like prisoner of war uh the
correlations there
this enslavement treatment that they
have
it's so brutal uh but but in ways that
also feel more psychological Than
Physical while there is physical ones I
I think I think they're doing such an
excellent job of fleshing it out but
they are making everything feel like
such turmoil
um for everyone on the on the Rebellion
side and the fights should barely even
be gone yeah they're just perceived as a
threat right now
you know yeah we're still dealing with
the aftermath of their first major
Series right yeah that's they haven't
even really done much yet yeah and it's
like no when you shut this [ __ ]
any Insurrection Must Be Stopped I love
it love it so much but
um yeah I mean there's more to to touch
on
go ahead John
thank you I appreciate that uh no no
yeah this was
um easily perhaps the most sort of
Maybe not maybe not the most tense
episode but it had a specific kind of
tension that uh permeated kind of every
scene that did feel yeah like you can
feel the pinch of everything and the
precariousness of everything and just
every storyline we checked in with had
some kind of dread quality to it even
watching did Ramiro you know pretty much
keep succeeding uh even still be like
with that you know there you see the
harshness of the way they you know do
their interrogation and the weird
disconnect in the emotionality of that
she's really enjoying it and then her
doctor guy is like super Pleasant and
like completely detached from the
implications of the entire thing and you
keep cutting back and forth and yeah I
love the geography of all that because
you can feel the urgency from the Empire
even though they still feel like they
have the upper hand you feel the urgency
from you know the people in the Senate
position who have the most arguably at
this moment to lose mon Mothman her
cohorts and Vel and whatnot and then you
have Andor and the prisoners and I and I
love yeah what you pointed out about
Andy Circus it really you really really
feel that sense of a guy who has had to
create this Persona as a means of both
getting through this for a personal uh
point but also for
actually you know helping others to do
so and it's an easy kind of vibe that
wouldn't come across that way like you
said he comes across like this hard ass
but you can always tell and especially
hear that he's doing it for you rather
than to you or at least that seems like
how he's kind of looking at it and I did
really love the internal play they did
with him you know especially and or keep
you know poking at him about like what's
going on how many guards are there or
you know we're trying to find out what's
going on on too and you know even in a
system like this that you know you
you're being punished and to some degree
oppressed uh you know you can watch as
he is even being broken of that Paradigm
you know coming out of that belief
system and yeah maybe at least if not
living long enough to join the Rebellion
at least coming to a place where you can
tell he will do something significant
for the cause or that will ultimately
contribute to the cause and I think he's
portrayed that beautifully and the whole
thing with ooloff and you get the
combination of both things it's like you
get this individual guy who's very close
to us who's on our level and you see how
they treat him and you kind of get I
thought the doctor was an interesting
character because that's a person who is
you'd be maybe relieved to see but who's
also like a prisoner too he ain't got
shoes on so he's clearly not in any kind
of position of power and the more you
learn in this limited capacity Yeah the
more you really
start to wonder like oh yeah they're
probably even though they've coerced us
into believing in this game and they've
created this manipulation to make the
prisoners you know compete with each
other and and you know be more
productive yeah it's not really for
anything and it's really just about
surveillance and keeping an eye on you
or keeping you under the thumb and uh
yeah all that I like that they really
waited to give you the reveal of what
really happened down onto and you have
everybody trying to get the information
and you just have that frantic quality
of communicating across the thing and it
just seems like things are getting worse
but we can't really tell why or what and
I think that's an important part too
because in especially the prisoner's
position your mind has to be running
wild and it's already enough trouble to
keep yourself sane but then to also then
find out you know what this this sterile
Factory really is for and perhaps you
know what the true true outcome will be
for each of these prisoners is quite
Sinister in a whole other way and you
see the the sort of just
true cruelty of the punitive measures of
the empire
which I mean you know they've been
illustrating but I think here is
especially I don't know there are always
arguments about the ethics of how we
treat our prisoners and how we uh
achieve the retrieval of information and
this definitely highlighted both of
those things and even how we treat our
allies in getting that information you
know that whole awkward exchange between
Deidre and Cyril like I I'm fascinated
by what they're trying to do with that
relationship and uh and the way that
they are clearly aligned but not aligned
and I wonder what is going to become
that friction
um but yeah this was incredibly uh just
it's like a great continuation but also
had a nice sort of uniquely Dreadful
quality to it you know
yeah yeah I think so I think what
they're doing with mon mothma is very
fascinating she's
she's someone who I have like prior to
especially this show has always been
this sort of uh
elegant Regal character someone who you
see she's always look like some kind of
Angel you know
um
this Shining Light but
but here we really get to see she's had
it really rough like she's got a
struggle and she has to deal with
like even in her like this it's one of
those cases of the secret identity is
really the one she presents to Coruscant
you know those motivations and and the
the the divisive political figure the
one that she puts forward
when the real her is the one who's like
helping out with the Rebellion
and and care so much about the souls
like that part of her political side has
that personality I'm saying that you
know she has like the big secret of what
she's really doing and she's not really
feeling like buddy buddy with the Empire
and such
and on both sides she seems like she's
just crept on yeah nice and Coruscant no
respect and then the Rebellion side of
like yeah I'm trying to funnel all the
money and everyone's kind of giving me
crap about my family it doesn't seem my
daughter hates me my husband hates me
Lutheran seems to just kind of abuse his
power like he just keeps nothing seems
to be lining up well for her and she
keeps trying her best and trying to
remain strong and I really like what
they're doing with fleshing her out and
and also with Val
um there's a character that I do find
interesting and I like I I did they
really didn't sell me on the
the she was someone who comes from
poverty and that she's someone who just
comes from the muckiest parts of the
world as well like now one part of her
seemed to indicate that she would be of
wealth
and come to find out that oh she does
have kind of You said Batman kind of a
Batman thing going on here where oh
you're actually you're financially fine
yeah you're you're you have your [ __ ]
together but that's not what you're
really all about like who you really are
in the shadows I think is a really cool
uh consistent theme to keep drawing and
the way they I thought the show was
shaping up Cyril to be the main
antagonist because he was our
introductory antagonist
uh it looks like it's going to be Deidra
who's going to be the main antagonist
and perhaps some type of partnership
that seems like that will form between
them that seems to be on a whole other
kind of demented level because they're
both kind of psychotic in their own ways
like that whole exchange that they had
outside like Cyril's just socially like
messed up he is he's a bizarre
individual and I'm like that's not your
mom you know like whatever relationship
you think you're you can't you don't get
with your mom that's you're not gonna
get that here with her and I think you
think that's what's happening but that's
not what you're really getting and the
way she reacts to him is you can there's
a part of her that does seem a little
bit
like she knows I shouldn't interact with
him and he's doing some very unethical
things I could have this man killed but
there is a other part of her that
there's a reason why she hasn't and
she's slightly drawn to him too I just
they they just seem like some type of
Twisted little horror tale of characters
that would
come together they look like the kind of
characters who would like make out but
like put their mouths like on the on the
inside of their teeth under their lips
and just saliva dripping and and their
mouses clam together
and their bedroom role plays she dresses
up as his mom and punches
they're very weird weird Duo but I've
been lying if I said I wasn't intrigued
by the Grim sci-fi quality of slapping
those two kinds of characters together
because she seemed pretty normal at
first but the more she gets more we get
to know her the more you're like oh no
you're pretty messed up ladies
the the status you're at within this
organization yeah and then Bix is being
propelled now a lot of these characters
are just survivors who I feel like with
with Andor and Bix a lot of these
characters are people who are survivors
who look out for themselves and now
they're being pushed in the situations
where there's survivors who are going to
be looking out for a greater cause now
and fighting for that so I think that's
a big part of what that the Triumph of
the human spirit is of the Rebellion
like they really capture that with this
show of this is what the Rebellion had
to
triumph over like they paint they flesh
it out in a way that feels like a real
thing you know and it's like bizarre
like I'm talking about something that's
not a real history account but it feels
that way so yeah it's impressive it's an
impressive show yeah a lot of sex appeal
all around like that old guy who died I
know he was so hot I was so bummed and
whoever this you know Thug guy is who's
gonna fun bun Mothman I bet he's sexy
too I say he was a Senator or something
um I'm not Senator but he's like someone
like she called him I thought it was a
like an insult about him yeah that's not
his life yeah position I forget exactly
what they what they referred to him as
but yeah some kind of like clearly they
have an ethical sort of divide between
them but that's also part of I think you
know that's easily part of this
conversation is yeah no matter which
side you're on you're going you're going
to be forced into a position where
you're gonna have to deal with somebody
unsavory who it might not look good on
paper for you to be dealing with but
they're the one with the means and so
we kind of have no choice yeah but I'm
sure they're going to show up in some
fashion and are and our pilot whoever
that may be
I hope uh
where was the last time we had eyes on
Sinta I hope she's okay
placenta yeah the girlfriend yeah
because she could take care of herself
and she's got a whole bunch of different
skills and she was like on her own
moving around and stuff like that so
part of me is like oh God she get did
she get cinched
or is it going to be my juice probably
exploring her options you know that's
right do I want to stick with this
Rebellion
yeah you know it seems like a lot of
trouble and it seems like a lot of long
distance you know it's hard to do
relationship
and when Andy Circus is hunched over he
looks like Gollum still I love that
alrighty guys that's it for Andor tune
in next week or and or you know how it
goes all right I'll see you guys
[Music]